welcome back ladies and gents today
we're going to talk about king of thorns
a sci-fi surviving drama as for what
exactly this movie's about well let's
dive into it in the crowded streets of
new york city people are minding their
business until a busty lady comes
falling from the sky just like any other
typical day however what was untypical
about this death is that instead of
cleaning blood and brain pieces off the
ground the health organization had to
isolate the area as they're dealing with
a disease called the medusa virus
doctors around the world couldn't find a
cause or a cure to the medusa strain a
newscaster narrates that in its first
stage the disease is in an incubation
period for 30 to 60 days from infection
and in the second stage the body starts
turning to stone petrification within 12
hours
so far the fatality rate is a hundred
percent throwing the world into chaos
under the economic collapse and rising
political tension a russian businessman
named ivan vega announces that his group
venus gate are searching for possible
cures and he continues to say that the
ice will conquer the stone implying
they'll find a cure for the disease in
the coolest way possible on the other
half of the world u.s officials meet to
discuss the possibilities of the medusa
virus being a bio weapon developed by
venus gate and the vegas out of his mind
after further discussions in knowing
that the u.s president has passed away
from medusa the officials agreed to spy
and possibly sabotage venus labs naming
the mission the most ridiculous name
sleeping beauty
three buses transport people to the
venus gate lab stroke castle these
people have volunteered to be put in a
hibernation state after scientists
concluded if they freeze the body before
the virus kicks in they'll stop the
petrifying process
inside the castle a receptionist takes
the information of the main character
kasumi and hands her a bracelet then
she's told that she has to leave her
twin sister shizuku who's a cheerful
confident ray of sunshine so she can
attend the briefing that chairman vegas
doing for the guests at the end of the
briefing abita asks a very reasonable
question to the sigma russian man what
if the guys running the place die while
the volunteers are frozen the sigma
responds with a smug face the castle is
controlled and managed by an ai system
called alice this system also helps in
monitoring the physical and emotional
state of the resident through the
bracelets on their wrists we then see
kasumi sitting alone looking at her
bracelet underneath it we can see a scar
on her wrist implying signs of self-harm
and depression kasumi contemplates going
through the hibernation knowing she'll
be alone for a hundred years without her
loving supportive sister now outside the
girls have themselves a quarrel as
kasumi doesn't want to go through the
sleep alone so her sister despite
visibly looking sad of the separation
tells her that she believes that they
eventually meet again the next day
arrives and the volunteers are handing
their personal belongings before going
through some tests to be put in chambers
that look like they're straight out of
the matrix inside it the ai calms gasumi
before starting the freezing process
after we see some soldiers firing guns
and we get a flashback of the wholesome
moment between the girls
gasumi awakens alongside the other
people they're shocked to see that the
facility they're in is covered by vines
filled with thorns while looking around
some sort of mutated bat lands on
kasumi's chamber sending her flying to
the ground luckily she gets caught by
two guys who ask her what's wrong when
she points up a swarm of jurassic bats
fly down and if i'm being honest what
bothered me the most wasn't the blood
and gore but the balls hanging on their
birds anyway after managing to
forcefully open the elevator door people
fall to their death because they're
going in without realizing there's no
elevator out of that death pit a hellish
monster rises and tries to catch an old
geezer but the giza gets saved by
garsumi and a blonde guy who gets caught
by the monster's tentacle and crushed to
death
after [ __ ] just settles down a group of
survivors made up of a boy a blonde
hottie a four-eyed middle-aged man an
olgiezer a cop a criminal and kasumi sit
around and try to figure things out the
group's big alpha males have themselves
a quarrel but the hot blondie sells it
low-key making her the mom of the group
soon after they decide to go to the
upper levels the group wraps their bare
feet with pieces of t-shirt so the
thorns won't be a huge issue as they
make their way up the tower garsumi
tries to figure out why marco the jacked
up criminal looks so familiar the group
soon comes to a dead end flooded in
water where they'll get cornered by a
monster that detaches the old giza's
head when the group wants to run from it
they get shouted at by tim the little
boy who tells them that the monster is
called a demon saurus and it tracks prey
using sound because it's got poor vision
marco asks timothy shaw and then throws
him along with catherine the blonde hot
babe into the water after that the group
members jump in themselves
on the other side catherine notices
gasumi is nowhere to be found marco
looks for her and finds her unconscious
under the water he saves her with the
help of peter the four-eyed middle-aged
man after bringing back gasumi the group
finds they're surrounded by a dozen
demonsaurus the fellas run for the hills
as marco tries to slow down the monsters
when they reach a semi-open gate the
fellas find some guns and blast the ugly
bastards after surviving this wave the
fellas regroup in a security room where
they treat the minor injuries and reload
their weapons while trying to figure out
their situation from the computers in
the room
now here's something that weirded me out
catherine suddenly had a mental
breakdown and threatens to slap tim then
she wakes up from a state hugs a little
boy and apologizes to him ron the cop
makes a witty remark about catherine
hiding something from her past marco
says nah buddy she ain't it peter's the
imposter so they drill in with questions
until he snaps and takes cars to me as a
hostage and runs to the elevator in the
elevator peter makes an interesting
remark saying what the hell are you then
the camp cuts to the boys packing some
heat preparing for the rescue mission
however unbeknownst to them a horde of
demon soros is surrounding them which
puts the rescue mission on hold they now
need to sneak their way further up the
tower via a broken bridge covered with
thorns
all goes smooth until kathy's hand gets
stung by a thorn alleging the demons saw
us to their location marco acts quickly
and shoots a fuel container exploding
the area beneath them now like the total
thrill of drama this movie is it cuts to
some depressing flashbacks of kasumi's
past after a spin in the twisted
dreamland gazumi wakes up inside a lab
with samples of monster she then hears
peter talking to someone who turns out
to be marco apparently they were working
together when marco leaves the room
peter goes to talk to garcimi as he
knows she was listening he hands her a
chip that contains valuable info about
medusa before being killed by a demon
soros when the demon source turns to
kasumi marco enters the room and shoots
the thing then they run for their lives
however the monster is relentless and
keeps chasing till they reach a hole in
the ceiling with the monster behind them
they can't climb up as marco battles it
out with the monster mano amano gazumi
suddenly drops the chip which catches
fire from the molotov cocktails ron and
kathy threw at the monster
soon after that the group who are now
back together makes their way to a
storage room marco confronts the group
about his identity it turns out that the
thug is a second lieutenant sent by the
us to blow the facility up if the
suspicions were true suspicions the
venus gate made medusa as a bio weapon
however the confession session was cut
short when the floor started shaking and
something started smashing the door that
something was none other than the
russian sigma male dr ivan vega the ceo
of venus gate dr vega comes forward with
what happened he says a test subject
went out of control and had gone beyond
his reach we learned from dr vega that
this whole hibernation thing was just a
study to learn how to control dreams and
forge them into a reality now on their
way up through a hidden passage dr vega
leads the group we learn how the story
began as vegan narrates that eight years
ago meteorites lit up the sky above a
siberian village all the residents died
from an unknown disease except one girl
the ministry suspected a contagion but
the issue was a creature which cut
through his troops like butter they
fought it and brought it down in a hail
of bullets torn to shreds this thing was
the strangest creature he'd ever laid
eyes on the laws of biology that govern
all known life simply didn't apply to it
the creature had sprung fully formed
from the girl's imagination turns out
the girl the little demon monkey and
medusa are all connected vega continues
by bringing the creature to life the
girls survived the effects of medusa as
vega continues talking about the events
that led to this point he walks them to
a room where alice is alice apparently
passed away but her consciousness still
lives as an ai vega tries to end his
life by taking a gun that was hidden
under the glass coffin but kasumi and
marco stop him and demand that vega take
them to the test subject that went out
of control as she suspects by now that
it's actually her sister however the
thorn vines come bursting out of the
ground and tim runs away and the
feathers follow him their path was cut
by the demon who refuses to die so marco
as usual stayed behind to fight them
right when it seemed that marco's time
was up a sword went right through the
demon's throat saving marco but in the
process peter gets petrified sacrificing
his life in the chattest way possible
the fellows running after tim reach yet
another dead end in an old abandoned
well when marco rejoins the group we
know that alice hijacked the boy's body
and guided them to this point claiming
she's protecting the suitable host as
that's her mission she then dipped out
and tim regained control
backed against the wall the group
decides to jump into the rising water as
it's their only way to survive after
some hiccups the group's now on the
outside of the castle they look around
and see the castle is covered by thorns
garcimi walks up to the hill where she
lasted with her twin sister and sees a
cam on the ground she turns it on and
watches a recording of her sister having
some sort of seizure before the
recording cuts out she comes to the
realisation that this thorn stuff is the
work of her sister's dreams she runs
back to the castle and marco tries to
stop her by calling her name and asking
her to come back with them saying that
her sister isn't the girl that she
remembers anymore gartemi refuses and
proceeds to enter the castle while marco
tim and catherine go to a helicopter
flying it to the castle that's turned
into a dragon what's more wacky is
catherine's pulling a gun on marco she
tells him to fly away as she wants to
live peacefully ever after with tim as
her new son after her own son was lost
going into the facility marco tells her
there's no out running this [ __ ] as it
will engulf the whole world with its
thorns meanwhile gazumi is still
searching for shizuku by using a
computer to locate her position back on
the outside marco is giving a wonderful
review about the sleeping beauty story
and as he continues catherine starts
coughing and shoots the gun multiple
times by mistake this makes the
helicopter swing out of control hitting
a vine that sends marco flying outside
however our man manages to hold on to a
metallic piece from the castle roof
before re-entering the castle from a
window luckily for him he lands in the
same room kasumi's in she asks if tim
and kathy are okay and he replies he
doesn't think so after seeing them crash
by the side of the castle
now inside again marco decides to help
garcia find her sister they run towards
the location we see everything turned to
stone alongside catherine who died
holding little tim when marco and
carsimi reach the lab marco starts
having illusions he sees his own sister
who died from medusa not only that this
fake sister starts kicking his ass but
it turns out it's alice that's
controlling marco's consciousness and
kicking his ass she explains to him all
the steps that led to this situation and
that medusas a mental virus that mainly
infects those with trauma as their minds
focused and at the same time fragile
enough for the virus to take control
while she's talking marco starts
analyzing the situation and concludes
that she's controlling his consciousness
through the chip team venus gate
injected into the volunteer's necks so
he shoots himself in the freaking neck
snapping back to reality marco shuts
down alice's system but while doing so
he takes a heavy blow to the stomach on
the other end gazumi means also having
illusions a dream within a dream within
a dream and by god it was actually hard
knowing what was real as well as what
was going on in real time i do advise
you to watch the last 30 minutes as it's
suspenseful anyway moving on kasumi
starts talking to a clone of shizuku
made from thorns thorne shizuku urges
kasumi to leave and go and live her life
peacefully however kasumi declines and
demands to talk to the true shizuku thus
the clone ties guards to me with vines
but kasumi doesn't back down and tries
to brutally escape the vines hurting
herself in the process
assad shizuku sees it and gets
overwhelmed to the point that she starts
losing control of the vines outside when
alice finally shuts down fully shizuka
loses control of her dream giving kasumi
an opening to crawl to her sister's
unconscious body the clone re-emerges
and holds kasumi by the leg asking her
not to look at shizuku's body however
kasumi manages to pull through when she
looks at shizuka's wrists she starts
having flashbacks about all that's
happened turns out when her sister went
to the hill kasumi was so upset of going
through the sleep alone she attempted
double suicide shizuku refusing to die
holds onto the ledge and when she looked
down we see kasumi dead
are you following then lads i repeat
kasumi died a while ago after witnessing
such a painful event shizuku's
imagination of having a sleeping beauty
scenario where she's with her family
sleeping in a castle surrounded by
thorns came to reality as far as the
dead sister part goes shizuku dreamed
her sister to life hence this gosummy
we're seeing now is from shizuku's
imagination she dreamt her sister back
to life all this gets revealed the
castle collapses so to save kasumi
shizuku pushes her out of the collapsing
roof way with a golden vine she then
gets caught by marco and they jump out
of a window into the ocean apparently a
big sister's works never done as shizuku
sprung vines to catch them and slowly
put them on the ground now that the
smoke settled marco asked skarsami to
live a happy life as his dying wish the
man dies sitting up with a smile on his
face kasumi kisses him on the cheek then
goes and looks for any people in the
area alongside little tim who's still
alive
oh that was quite a movie i loved all
the twists and turns and to fully
appreciate them you've got to watch the
end of the movie anyway that's it from
us we hope you enjoyed the video and if
so you know what to do we'll see you in
the next one